Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to "Resident Evil 7"
Now the observant ones among you may have already caught on
and those that weren't paying attention and just watching in the back ground
HEY that's no different I love you just the same
but you may have noticed the webcam is slightly different
I could go into detail of why
but I'll let you sort it out in the comments below
I've got shit to do
and the first thing I'm gonna be doing is "Ethan Must Die"
I would go back and do  Uh, the Nightmare
banned footage, but I've actually been playing that on my own and I'm very good at it now So
I'm going to uh-play that at the end of it
and I'm just gonna blast through a round because I actually find it to be really fun.
But we've already covered that
so I want to start with the stuff that I have not yet done and that all comes down to
"Ethan Must Die"
And I, am ready-
*in-game screaming* to die.
Owww
*Creepy laughing in-game*
"This hellish house has been constructed
but for ONE purpose: to kill intruders.
No saves, items are randomized each time,
countless traps and monsters await.
Ethan will most likely die here
but fear not even in death you can still retry again and again and again."
Okay, so this is kinda like the, um, the nightmare mode which was kind of like, uh..
a survive the waves type killing floor type deal
where you've got to craft up your own stuff with resources that you get.
But this is interesting. This is insane.
No one could get through this!
We've all felt that way-
Oh okay, never mind. Defeat Marguerite in the greenhouse.
OH.
I only have a knife?
Alright, I don't - okay, alright.
We're going in this with just a knife alone.
Okay then..
Well, at least I'm back to Ethan and I'm not Clancy anymore.
Nothing wrong with Clanc-
*Explosion, followed by Ethan screaming and dying*
Woahhhh... Uh, okay I'm dead.
Well - haha
*Shrugs*
Alrighhht,
well, hahaha
jokes on me, hey,
I'm just asshole who sees a box and pokes at it with my knife.
Well, fuck me. Right?
(Sigh)
"The items in crates and boxes are mainly randomized each time.
Whether or not you get what you need is a matter of luck.
However you can get an idea of the value . . . ."
OHHH!
So did I just get randomly screwed?
Randomly generated box explosion? Is that what that was?
Is that- that... Woah. What the heck is that?
"Ethan Winters lies here."
Thanks.
Is it gonna blow up?
*Grunt*
OHHH, (Oh)
Okay.
I literally just got randomed in the ass.
And blown to SMITHEROONS.
Well, okay, game.
Two can play at that game... Game.
And I'll show you how good game I be at this game.
When I blast Marguerite away..
With my skill.
*Whispering* Where the hell am I?
Better carry on...
Huh.
Am I in Bloodborne?
Alright Marguerite, I've got a knife. And a will to live.
But I'm probably gonna die, but hey, let's see what happens.
Oh.
Alright then, can't use that here.
"Find the greenhouse key in the living room in the main house."
Well...
Wish I would've known that before I wasted all my time tracking back here.
I was kind of already at the main house and then I
decided to come back around because I thought that the game was gonna
continue in the greenhouse,
where I was first told to go.
But alas! I am dumb!
I know there's probably secrets lying around everywhere but I'm gonna--
*Growling*
Aah, shitty dudes!
OH, that ain't good!
Oh!
Someone's awfully pukey up there!
I don't like that!
Can you not? Uuh
Well, I have some experience with fighting these guys with just a knife before.
Ouch, Owwie, wow, ow, okay.
Alright then, oh. Well heh.
Hey, okay, I'm beginning to think that this isn't supposed to be beaten
and I am just a big bag of dicks.
"If you find a wooden crate, don't go busting it open at first sight
It could be filled with explosives ready to ruin your perfect run.
Check it out first,
if there's anything different about the tape.."
Ah, okay..
That would've been a good clue to start out the game with
but you didn't do that to me because you're an a-hole.
Oh there's not even a thing here now...
Ookay, I'm getting nothing.
Fine...
Alright so...
Oh, thanks, that's good...
Ah!
Goddamn hell with your puke showers!
Alright so,
I don't know..
I don't know if this is gonna be a matter of frustration
Is there anything different about this tape?
Nothing that I could see. Ha-boof--
*Ethan yells and dies*
I think the tape had a little bit of a wire under it, and that was the difference.
Welp, third death's the charm, let's just keep getting at this.
I have no idea...
It's yellow..
Alright then I guess that's good then.
Oooh, another one.
Oh let's see.. I wonder.
Hmmm..
Looks a little,
Looks a little different, me thinks it might be EXPLODY
but let's check.
Not..? I have a gun now.
Ooh, this is going to be even MORE different than I thought it would be
So now, at least I have a chance..
*Whisper-Mumbling* I didn't really have a chance before with just a knife.
ALRIGHT, I got a gun now.
It's not gonna be able to kill the big guy,
but at least it'll be able to kill one of the little guys.
Hey, can I shoot you guys in the face?
That - woah, hey.
Watch yourself..
Could hurt yourself.
Ha-boom!
Aaand ha-boom!
Oh yeah, bam, you're dead.
Okay, anybody else?
Oh, ah, Shit
Needed that bullet.
Plam-- Oh, two shots and you dead?
Why you keep doing that..
Uhmm..
Hm.
I'ma assume that's good but I'ma shoot it anyway-
aight it was good I didn't need to waste any bullets here, I'm a dum-dum.
SO I can't kill you.. But...
Ha-boop- Ah, It was 'splo-sion.
Alright, so I'm out of bullets officially but at least I have a gun,
and that's good and..
.. Kinda one of the items I actually have...
So, if I can find some gunpowder,
or anything... I could grab me up some goodies...
So, the long and the short of it I gotta get by that guy.
Don't you puke on me--
Oooh hey... *Yelling* Waay!
Ah, fucking god damn it!
You son of an asshole!
Why you doin' this to me?
Oh, where am I goin'?
I don't now where I'm goin' I only gotta knife. I'm fucked
Help me!
Somebody help me please!
There's a mad monster chasing me.
Think it might be Mad Mike.
Tryna sell me some draaa-uggghs.
OH GOD!
I saw the, uh, the wire registered for me
just a little too late on that one
just a hair too late, teensy, teensy amount late.
Well, I am dead.
Lots of- Waaah. Okay..
Alright don't mind me, don't mind me, don't mind *me x5*
Don't minnd meeee. *singing*
I'm just gonna duck,
under here, and smash--
*Yelling* Aw come on! What was that?!
What the fuck!
Why did it bl-eu?
Was he that close behind me? He must have been.
I'mma risk it!
I didn't have any shit in the other one anyway.
Oh a shaa-wot gun-- God dammit.
*Lots of God Dammit's*
Okay who wants some?
You want some?
Bodi-boo!
Oh, frick-a-dick.
Oh no, oh no! Noo!
At least my shotgun is there! At least my shotgun is right there.
Because, then if I get that then I'm gonna get that and then.. It's- it's gonna-- blow my..
Gravestone to pieces, it's gonna be good.
Alright, listen up
I'm gonna level with you, whoever is in that house right now, you need to listen to me,
Markiplier,
because I'm the man here.
And if you kill me..
I'm gonna come back and haunt you as a ghost.
So if you even try to come close to me I'm gonna pull your ass out of your face,
and then run it back though, and then you're gonna be - fuck!
I knocked my light over.
I'm - It's gonna be a constant loop of pain as you keep regurgitating yourself going back up in your own ass!
Alright, now that I've leveled with you, I'm gonna go in there and you're gonna treat me kindly.
Like a neighbor would.
So don't..
*Stammering* Don't sneak on me-
Is what I'm trying to say here, so don't sneak on -
Hah, slash.
Alright.
The hash-sling slasher strikes again - Hah!
Gimmie the - yeah, I got a shotgun.
And it's got ammo!
Hell yeah! Okay, you know what?
Boom! *sarcastically* Oh no, are you dead?
Hahaha
So is there something over here that I can utilize-- *really quietly* no..
Uh oh.
Ah, two of them! That's not what I was hoping for..
Ah that's locked, good, great.
Okay maybe I can knock both if they're.. *Shouting* Lined up like that!
Ahhh don't do it don't - ah!
Fuck me then, I'm an asshole.
*Singing*I'm gonna get my shotgun back.
*still singing* But I don't think I can get past that guy.
Don't.
Uhh..
Ah ha -
Glasses?
Ow! Why?
What the hell do glasses do?
Why do I need glasses?
I mean I get that my vision - *realization* Ohhh... That's why I need glasses.
*feared noises* Sorry, s'cuse me.
Oh geez don't do anything to me. Oh my God.
Ohh, my God.
S - Oh my God,
this tells me what's in the boxes!
*Oh my God repeated 9 times quickly*
I need to keep this.
I have to keep this, this tells me exactly what boxes are good and which boxes are bad.
Oh my God!
*notices enemy*
Oh my God- do not, please, dear God, do not.
I am really really struggling here, and you need to be nice to me because..
If you don't, you're an asshole-- Ah, that didn't go anywhere.
Well shit, okay, if I can close this..
And then, I'm gonna try sneaking again. Hoh boy.
(quietly muttering "don't kill me" repeatedly)
Just blast yourself, and then go the fuck away.
Blast yourself to itty-bitty pieces- please kill 'em.
(explosion)
Yes!
Okay, is it gonna kill it though?
Yes! Yes! Yeaass!
Okay..
That's good.
Oh my God..
And I've got gunpowder.
Oh shit.
Oh shit..
Oh snap!
Okay,
so I'm about to die, but...
I'm actually -
I think..?
Please be..?
I got a survival knife. I dunno what that do.
Gunpowder.
Okay..
So..
This is the farthest I've gotten.
These glasses...are frickin' amazing.
Improves your vision so you can see where items are located?! That's so good!
That's so good!
Aw, that's so good!
Oh my God - okay, so - but I'm still in trouble here because I...
am stouUuck
I don't have a gun.
I have bullets,
and the means to make bullets, but no gun, I'm gonna--
*mid-burp* Saaave that chem,
just in case I find a herb or something.
Don't hear anything..
Psychostimulants, which is exactly the same as with the x-ray glasses would do, but it doesn't run out..
Aw, fuck, I got so many items, but no way to use them, I am...
I - I have a gun!
That is true, I have a gun, but if I even get clipped by the tiniest bit of the puke from that guy,
I'm DEAD.
Instantly dead, so I gotta get back outside.
Wha- What?
Why's that locked?
What?!
But they can't be serious here! Why would that be locked?
Do I gotta go d -
*in-game growling*
Ooh.. Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit.
*yelling while firing* Ahn!
Okay, did I get you?
Okay, good.
Don't try to fuck with me, bro.
Don't try to mess with me.
Oh God that's bees! Ohh that's bees! I do not have enough to deal with that, ooh.
Okay, so I gotta get through there...
But I don't have enough stuff to do that.
That's locked.
Was there another-- uh-...
*random yelp of confusion*
*another random MoAn*
So I'm gonna do my best, I'm gonna try and shotgun that.
Well that worked out surprisingly well, I didn't think that that was gonna entirely go on one go.
*Quietly* Okay...
Oh this place is familiar.
Well that's a trap on the ground, I recognize that.
Okay, probably-- Oh God.
That looks awful.
Okay.
Well, that's- that's a problem.
I think I remember it saying something that it w- didn't activate right away.
And you're just supposed to just run over it?
Oooh, that's- that's a bad idea.
Oh boy.
I'll just try to go over.. Over here-
...Okay..
Yes, okay.
Please..
Please, I'm begging you.
Hoo, okay.
Okay, that's a bomb. That's definitely a bomb.
'Cause there's no item marker on that, so that's definitely a bam.
Okay.
So this-- I'm- I'm legitimately sweating bullets here, because..
Oh fuck that's not what I wanted!
Okay..
Just lemme go back-- okay.
So if I let him go over this trap..
The way this works, is as a nerve gas in the nightmare mode, it stuns them.
So if he comes through here, and goes on that, I can slash him up.
Hey buddy.
Gonna- woahh, woah woah.
C'mon, C'mon.
That's right, c'mon!
Can you not get through that door?
Ayeee!
Heeey!
Okay, C'mon, C'mon through.
No, godammit.
(Frustrated sigh)
AH! God DAMN it, you asshole!
You peekaboo motherfucker!
You sack of shiiit!
Ohhh there are 2 items in there, good (x4) goOOod
GoOoOoOd!
Br-come on--
BLAAM!
Dead? Alright it's dead, ok
Habooski
Bambooski
Whoa, okay then, steroids baby!
I love me some steroids--! "Strengthen muscles and increases max health. Effect lasts indefinitely."
Hell yeah! Use that right away!
Now I won't die in one hit hopefully, I'll die in like, one and a half hits, maybe.
"Your max health increased."
Great!
Does that carry over from death to death? I hope so
Alright, stand on this, buddy.
Hey buddy, stand on this.
You didn't- *bang* Stand on it!
Asshole.
Alright, c'mon..
Nothing else here.
Just you and me, buddy.
You and me.You and me, and your biig...
Rrrrround head!
Okay- oh, where'd your head go? Where'd your big round head go?
I was just talking about it- I'm gonna tell all my friends about it.
Okay.
So..
*In game movement sounds*
Sooo...
Tape looks a little dirty there.
I don't think there's anything wrong with it, but I just wanna be sure.
Okay, it was fine.
Gunpowder, though. That's good, I can make some strong bullets.
Which is good for me.
So with this pistol I'll actually be able to..
..Utilize those-- okay, so I got extra pistols, so that was..
Worth it, I think. Okay, just gotta be mindful for traps, cause--
*In-game growl*
Woah- okay, alright then. I'm just gonna...
*growl* you gonna- you gonna say hi?
you gonna say hi to me buddy?
*growl* watcha doin' over there?
can you not open the door?
mmhm tell me about it
tell me more
come on, I'm here to listen
I'm your friend...
eblerfimininlerr??
...that sounds bad, she left you?!
*growls*
Oh, i'm sorry...
You're married for 14 years?
You had like 17 thousand million kids!
*growls*
Y'know what I'm just gonna...
yeah, its pretty stinky- waaaayy ok
*growl intensifies*
Alright- what are you doing?
...and what am I supposed to do about this?
not really a choice that you give me here
Oh boy...
Well...
Okay, alright then, maybe it's just best to keep that closed.
AAH
Okay, there is a delay.
Alright, good to know.
It's just enough delay to have someone chasing me and... *mumbling*
Okay...
Are you dead?
Oookay.
I don't trust that.
Not even a little bit.
Even if I shot- oooh...
That's a thing over there.
Okay.
Flame thrower, baby.
Oh, that's just a chest.
Okay.
Alright!
I'll take this!
I don't like that...
I don't like that at all
Heey... Granade launcher!
Alrighty then, so our fourth star chest, is it guaranteed to always be good?
Yes, maybe so?!
God I wish I had my glasses
Yes..
Oh heyyyy
Oh boy
Woaah you got fubbernucked (?)
By your own traps, ye idiot
So they CAN walk over 'em
That's good to know
I'm just gonna open the door and-
WOAH HEY WOAH woah
woah woah okay ah I don't like that..
Do, do me a favor and just burn to death-
Ooooh
Fuck
Well, there went all my...more health
i told you just-
not a lot..
*growls*
*monster reaches out for markimoo*
Woah...what the fuck?
Did that kill him??
*explodes* WOAH, ok then
*surprised mark*
Well shit, I was about to say I dont wanna waste all my ammo...
Alright then, I'm doing good ok, Makin' progress
This is good I think? :I
*mumbling self-reassurances*
*some murmuring*
*Small exhale*
YEP! That was bad.
Kay, I can't waste my ammo, but I do have the option to
Make more if need be
I just don't wanna have to do that.
You dead? ( Cough)
Alright you're dead, trust me don't let me down man.
Kay! Can still kick those things, that's nice. I like that
Good exercise
Please tell me I don't have to fight jack
I dont wanna be able to to that. *Quietly*
*scary opening door sounds * Ooo, hello.
Alright where are you located dude?
Where are you?
I can't see you.
WELL!
Shit..
I dont know where it is, I can't get in there.
I dont even know if I wanna get in there anyways,
*clang*
kay
Hooooo, alrighty then, okay.
We're dealin with some uh fun times here
Please dont... get me from here *Quietly*
Woohoo
Alright
Okay
Got those outta the way
OH! I should've just let them do their work!
OH I'm an idiot, Oh I'm an idiot... I'm an idiot, I'm an idiot, I'm an idiot.
Aaah! okay
alright he's dead
Cool!
should let the
bams do their work but you know..
live and learn and then get loves and then American capitalism
will win, all the way.
Ohh, there was a goodie in there.
Okay, it was right around the door, that would've killed me easily
Okay
Ah, well that's worth getting.
Alright, I'm on the way baby, don't despawn on me.
I need, I need ya baby.
I need ya.
Ok, M37 so..
It's basically
just another shotgun, if I
had the option I would take the M21, *but*
M21, *but* seeing as I dont have much of an
have much of a choice, I'm just gonna stick with what I got.
I got. Hello? (mumbling)
I've been through this on nightmare mode.
Nothin' too scary.. (scary said in baby voice)
Ah...
Can't get me I'm too smart..
Oh god damnit really?
Really? That's what you're gonna *gun shot in-game* do ta me!
Ok. Alright. Don't fuck on me.
I am NOT *gunshot in game* ready to be fuckled with.
to be fuckled with.
I do not want to be fuckled with.
Do not-  Oh th- Just two,
okay, alright, just two it is!
Scare me for that shit..
Then fine, fuck you.
Reload on this one.. *in game gun reloads*
I gotta stop wasting my big gun ammo..
Oh, *gets louder* fuck yOU NO.
You don't.
You're still alive..Oh god x4
NO! *shots fired in game* Oh my god..  Oh my god.
omygod x6
Don't do that to me!
(intense mumbling)
Ok so as far as I know, I've just gone in a big ass circle
Dunno why.. But
I have.
I'm gonna lead with a shotgun just to blast them. *in game bang*
Blast them..
ok..
*door opens* Ah,
I remember you..
The, uh, contemporary art..
*in game noises* Yeesh don't do that...
Don't do that, stop clangin. Dunno how
much this game clangs..
oop, ok..lets just.. *flamethrower sounds*
*more flamethrower sounds*
Oh, alright then..
*flamethrower sounds*
*more flamethrower sounds*
*even more* Ok.
Still no chem to be able to
make those into anything, so I just..
Kinda not helpful to me..
Oh boy.. Lets just go..Is this new?
Is this new? No, it's not new..
is this new? I don't know. Is it
new? I can't remember.
No traps here.
*in game steps*
Oh, I wish I had some
*in game sounds*
Ah! Fucking noo!
No! I didn't even
notice it! Oh, god!
Come on!
Oh.. Man!
Oh.. God damnit.
That asshole!
oi!! Fuck..
No! *in game sounds* God damnit!
Are you kidding me! What the fuck!
What happened? I crouched!
You guys saw! I
crouched! I
looked at it and was like, 'Oh, that's
not good.' and then I crouched!
*in game sounds* (nevrous babling)
Oh boy.. That was
not a lot of space to work with..
Is.. Is it comin back or is it..
I assume that was it
Alright then..
Ok..Seems ok..
Oh boy..
Well this looks.. Sketchy as hell.
I'mma try that one.. Woa. No no no..
Hey.. *flamethrower sounds*
*explosion?* Ah! NO! God damnit! Are you kidding me???
Come on, you asshole!
You fucking asshole!!
You god damn son of a bitch!
Yay.. Handgun ammo..
That's so sweet..
Can't see anything..
Ok.. I did that.. Cool..
Got the bomb..
Alright,
none of those were good, as I suspected.
All were- woah.. okay..
Hello?
Anything here?
No? k...
Nope.. Ok, nothing in here...
Then all that was bullshit
If i'm mistaking, there's a big guy over here
No...
Oh, it is dark in here..
Alright then, this is disconcerting
*door opens*
Jack: What the hell-
*Jack screaming*
*Body thuds*
*dead*
What the fuck was that?
What the fuck was that!? (Again)
What the F-
WOAH
Oh, its a turret
Oh.
*turret beeping*
*Gunshot*
I don't know how to beat that
*Flamethrower sounds*
*More Flamethrower*
*Long dramatic sigh*
*Turret Shooting*
I guess i just stand here until it runs out of ammo, maybe?
Can I close this door, please
OH
It's out of ammo!
Finally
Alright then
*Molded screeching*
OH BOY
Alri- Oh god damn, I don't have enough ammo for that.
Oh nO
No nO NO
AHH
GOD DAMNIT NOO
Do not do that to me.
*Molded exploding *
Ok.
*Mark spitting*
*Whispering* Fucking assholes.
*Door creaks*
Oh, you sack of shit.
*explosion*
YEp, I figured as much
Oh hello
That's not good
So, it really is just straight in front of it or not at all
Barely
*gunshot*
*Sigh*
It is very limited range right in front of it
But not a lot
*Shooting* OoO
Alright we're ok
There we go that's something
M21, I'll take it
Again, first shotgun i've gotten
*flamethrower*
*Explosion*
*Turret beeping*
*beeping again*
*And again*
*...Again*
*Music intensifying
Oh shit
Oh God. Just go in here
I'll take care of you in here
Not really
Got em
I should've gotten that burner fuel
But,- no,i have no time for regrets
Time for, there's two bullets left on the shotgun
How do they expect me to beat Marguerite
how
How am I supposed to be able to do that
Is that an explodey barrel?
God I'm getting so much med.
I don't need med
I don't have enough space, that's okay. I'm gonna drop off...
Aiaiai I wish I had gunpowder, but I'm gonna drop off, the machinegun
Doesn't seem like a good idea at first but ya know what maybe I don't want it.
Oh
AH fucking god damn it NO no no no no no
Okay you are getting shotgunned
Ssssso hard!
In the face!
oh god damn that was not the face
But
alright
Oh, well I guess he decided to fall over again I guess
(More Burning)
There he is, he's dead. Well, I'm just gonna eat this herb cause I think it's gonna top me off.
I'm officially almost completely out of ammo.
Officially almost completely
WUUUUUUUuukay
Alright that was where that guy was.
So after I drop down here there is no going back.
NO!
Fucking.. *Chris screams in pain*
(Markiplier calmly raging)
How did I not see that?
How did I not see that.
That was so obvious.
Didn't look before I leapt.
But I was already in mid-air.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna run by.. then I'm gonna blow this up.
Oh shit! Oh goddamn it oh no. Nonono nono oh god
Just BLAM okay whoa. You know what I'mma try my best, Jesus Christ that went about as wrong as one could hope for.
(explosion)
Gurhahhar
I almost fucked myself over.... REAL BAD
Oh my god... I almost..I almost ended everything right there
Because I was to stupid.. to understand what I was doing
Shit.. Okay
So now I see this .. obvious bam
So how do I break this bam? There's two of them
Yea, that'll kill ya. Okay then.
Nah
There we go
That was one of them
Well I guess I don't need to fall on that one then
Oh fuck
I'm going to blast this because who knows what's in there
Flamethrower I don't want that. (Whispers) God damn it.
Okay
So apparently what I need is in the living room
and I'm right by that
Alright
Oh wha- NOOOOOO
God damn it
I was trying to play it safe
god I've died ever single trap beyond the one I just got passed
this is infuriating
What the fuck
WHAT?
(Whispers) God damn it
We're just about there. I can't believe I'm still playing
I've been recording for over two hours now
Buuuuut... I don't have enough space
of course I don't why would I?
Alright sooooo
I gotta make some concessions here
Cause I got this good gun and I got the burner
Which is all good fine and dandy... buuuuuuuut
Ohhhhhh. I don't need to use any meds I gotta get arid of something
I'm gonna get arid of the other pistol even though it has bullets in it
I hate doing that but I got the albert so it's good
Got it!
What now?
Wha- get outta here
I still have to beat Marguerite
I don't know how ima do that. If I don't beat Marguerite
after coming all this way I'm going to be fucked.
Aw.. Fucking-fuck you
Oh boy not you
Ahh where is my BIG BOY!
No..no..no..no
don't come here, don't come here big one, don't come here
Okay... Good enough
Good enough
Okay thank you
That was a bit of a kerfuffle
Ah I think I'm okay
So now I'm on in unexplored territory, and what? Did the moons not go red anymore?
Alright so I..I..I'm assuming that Ima need these
For some reason I don't know. Maybe I will maybe I won't
YUP! I figured as much. Oooh no it's a surprise
It's a brigade of crawlies
Okay he's dead
*Sighs* Running out of- I..I tell you this run has been the least item giving
of any. It may seem I gotta lot of stuff, but in reality
I have been scraping by with nothing to my name
Oh god damn it. Oh fuck you assholes
Burn, burn, burn, burn, burn, just burn, burn, burn
burn
Over there is the other one
burn (5x)
Ow...WHAT THE FUCK
WHAT THE FUCK I WAS FULL HEALTH. GOD DAMN IT!
I'm not doing it again I can't. I'm not doing it, I've been playing for two yea- two- two years
I've been playing for two years, two hours. Two hours straight
Man that is like a live stream
thing to do. Because I may have been super close to the end too!
Who knows? I don't think I was. But man it gets screwed based over random chance
I did finally figure out which one's where bombs and which weren't
but Ima go straight to Jack's 55th birthday party because I wanna
I wanna just get this over with, because I've been playing that one for too long
nah not gonna happen. Alright sooo I know that took a long time... For me
but not a long time for you. So I'm going to make sure this episode was worth it (Awe)
and not just a smorgishbogish (<Yea right) of me failing. So I'm gonna play
Jack's 55th birthday party. Bring food to Jack and feed it to him.
The faster you fill him up. The higher your rank will be.
Ohhhh make Jack eat it..Okay
(Direction's on screen)
I'm playing Mia, and I'm assuming this is when everyone's infected
And this is not gonna be fun
Okay.. Alright then... Jack-Jack. How ya doin?
I don't have any food for you. Are you ready kids?!
I don't know. The bakers hope you enjoy the party
Well okay...sto-stop gettin- stop gettin all in a huff. Ima gonna go for it.
Alright I'm doing it apparently
YAY. I'm gonna getcha food for your birthday! I.. don't know what this is
I think it was pepper, but I think you going to like it
Ooooooh what is that all about?
Why do you have things on your head? What is happing here?
What the fuck?
I don't know if this is the way it's supposed to be
(Markiplier noises) Skirt by here. Whoopy-dee-doop-doop. Ooooo
okay good thing I got a lot of skills in not being hit. Ahhh shit
Alright you want some pep-pepper?
Wooah geez. Spice?
Oh shit
I don't know. I'm sorry, it's just spices I though it was gonna be good for you. I'm sorry
Okay whoa. Why didn't I know about this?
Wait they never gave me this!
What the fuck is this shit?
I wanted this! God damn it. Alright fine then I didn't even know I could do this
Fuck
Alright then. Aw.. shit their after me alright. Hey nice hat! Whoooa okay alright then
Exploding into a-  smorgishbogish bonuses for me I think.. I don't know
Alright
Hello?
Shabuski
Oooh okay
Just gonna get this she- whaa
I can't fit it in my god damn hault
Fuck
I had to much- Ah I brought too much shit
Aw.. fuck
I guess I'll scrap this
You know what? I'ma start over because, thi- this obviously
I didn't know that I was supposed to be shooting anybody
I thought it was gonna be a happy birthday for Jacky boy
Just gonna shoot and run, don't mind me!
Get all the bonuses up in here cause I care about my Papa
Alright.
You know what, I don't need those, hang on - owie!
You see I have a life bar now, which is kinda nice, *incoherent mumbling*
Kay -Got that, got that, I don't know what it was that I got but
What is that? A blue blaster, I don't want a blue blaster do I?
Ok I don't know what that is...
Blep! Blap! Blipity blap!
Hit you right in your big stupid hat
shut up
Alright, let me just get the chicken which is good food
I can't even pick it up!
Goddamn it! I gotta come back for it.
This is a load of ass. Hello
Shut Up!
Jeez! Shut up.
You just whine and whine and I'm gonna wine and dine
you later. But don't worry about it
Alright I'm gonna go back up and get the goodies
Because I think I just need to combine the spice with another item and it's gonna automatically make it better right?
That's how this works right?
That's how love works right?
You just spice it up a little bit and hope the combination
is better than the-- oh son of a
Let's see what the blue blaster does...
(Game: Woohoo!)
Wooooo!
(Game: Get that food in my belly!)
I'm tryin'
oooh! It's blue and it's blasty!
Woah. Your just standin' by the doorway huh?
You think you can stop me?
My blue blasty's gonna blow you all the way!
Okay so I.. Apparently, I think I know how to do the better ranking
is you gotta go get the blue blaster and then
combine the spices with what you got.
And hopefully that's gonna make a good meal for papa!
Alright, so, we're gonna combine
this and this.
Alright okay so we got this good good good good GOOD stuff!
nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom!
I know! I know! Mhmmmmmm
THE best, you don't need to tell me twice
I already know all about it